the US Navy has made a stunning
admission naval officials yesterday
confirmed that three separate UFO videos
released by the New York Times in 2017
and previewed on the show are actually
genuine they do in fact show aerial
phenomenon the Navy cannot explain and
that in fact our understanding of
physics cannot explain the Navy also
recently sent a letter to congressman
Mark Walker saying that it takes UFO
sightings very seriously and is working
to investigate them Nick Pope is a
British journalist he wants
investigating UFOs for the UK Ministry
of Defence he joins us tonight to
explain the significance of this so Nick
this does seem like a change in the way
the Pentagon describes this phenomenon
is it yes it is up until this point the
Navy has said very little and in fact
they've left the door open sometimes and
almost implied look we might be dealing
with commercial drones or even balloons
but now what they've done is turn around
and said number one this is real and
number two this is unidentified aerial
phenomena that's the phrase that they've
used previously they've so said advanced
unknown aircraft now they're saying
unidentified aerial phenomena and that
is it's a term borrowed from the British
government we used it in the Ministry of
Defence and we meant UFOs so the US
government is admitting that they have
no idea what these things are that
they're probably not some Russian super
plane and nobody's paying attention to
this I mean this seems like a watershed
moment I mean we have all this tape of
objects defying the known laws of
physics right next to US military
installations the military admits that
why is this not page one news everywhere
well it should be absolutely these
aircraft carriers that many of these
UFOs have been interacting with
obviously these are billion-dollar
assets and if the official position of
the most powerful Navy in the world is
frankly little more than we don't
know what this is I don't think that's
good enough and I think clearly people
like Mark Walker don't think so either
and I would urge him to get the
classified briefing that other senators
have said they've received and maybe
within the bounds of not wanting to to
divulge classified information but maybe
some of these senators could then step
forward and and at least give us a clue
of what we're dealing with here so it
turns out it wasn't a weather balloon I
mean they've been telling us that for
$50 a weather balloon it's not a weather
balloon is it no absolutely not somebody
in the Pentagon must have they they say
we don't want to hypothesize about this
that's fine but there must be in the
Pentagon a best assessment and there
must be a view of what they're ruling
out we should be told there's obviously
some reason they're not telling us in 15
seconds hypothesized as to what that
reason might be well some secret too
terrible to be told but I think we
should be told or at least we we should
be hinted at yeah or maybe not they were
lying about it from 50 years maybe
there's a reason they have been I don't
know Nick it's starting to worry me I'm
grateful though that you have come on so
frequently to put it in context sports
good to see you tonight thank you